sie haben in deutschland eine
jahrhundertealte tradition und es gibt
sie in vielen dörfern die
schützenvereine
die schützenbruderschaft dem rheinischen
hackenbruch ist katholisch geprägt
glaube sitte heimat lautet ihre parole
seit jeher bis heute die eines
christlichen glauben sind und
christlichen grundwerte und kurze sätze
annehmen und sich dazu bekennen dass
muslime oder atheist hätte ich keine
chance
das ist erstmal formal nicht möglich
weil die schützenvereine zum brauchtum
gehören und weil das schießen auf eine
attrappe gekonnt sein will hat die
europäische gemeinschaft historischer
schützen beantragt dass das
schützenwesen in die liste des
immateriellen weltkulturerbes der unesco
aufgenommen wird
aber die kulturorganisation hadert mit
dem antrag hat ihn erst einmal
zurückgestellt
hauptgrund sind solche abschnitte der
vereinssatzung die die religiöse
vielfalt ausschließen sie sei nicht mehr
zeitgemäß finden volkskundler tradition
sind ja nicht etwas was man wie die
kaffeekanne von der oma in schrank
hinter glas stellt und ja nicht mehr an
fast und nichtmehr bewegt sondern das
ist etwas lebendiges was in der
gesellschaft aktiv gelebt werden muss
auslöser für den streit der unesco mit
den schützen ist ein fall aus dem
westfälischen senna mit hat gedigk
türkischer abstammung wurde dort
vergangenen sommer schützenkönig aber
mit einem muslimischen schützenkönig
drohte der bruderschaft der rauswurf aus
dem dachverband der konflikt hat sich
derart zugespitzt dass mittlerweile
weder gedigk noch seine bruderschaft und
auch nicht die unesco ein interview
geben wollen
der fall geht hat am image der schützen
genagt mehr und mehr vereine wollen sich
künftig weltoffener geben
die schützen in buschhoven bei bonn
hatten schon vor einigen jahren die
satzung geändert sie sind jetzt keine
bruderschaft mehr und nennen sich
sportschützenverein so können atheist
nun muslime aufgenommen werden
religion spielt hier keine rolle mehr im
gegensatz zum dachverband der leute aber
nicht alles was im kopf das war ganz
komisch für mich
die debatte um traditionelle und moderne
vereine hat auch die bürger im kleinen
ort buschhoven aufgebracht sie wollen
keinen verein in ihrem dorf der moslems
ausschließt
es gibt sehr viele menschen die das
nicht für gut befinden und sagen also
mit denen morgen war also nichts zu tun
haben
auch bei den schützen dem rheinischen
hackenbruch setzt sich allmählich der
gedanke durch dass der muslimische
nachbarn mit schießen sollte
von menschen und nicht von religion oder
einstellungen
jetzt will der dachverband seine
position noch einmal überdenken